[Música]
bienvenidos y bienvenidos al espacio de
cultura de france 24 42 millones de
euros en obras de arte bloqueadas en la
frontera entre finlandia y rusia el fin
de semana pasado las autoridades
finlandesas incautaron un cargamento de
cuadros esculturas y antigüedades
pertenecientes a varios prestigiosos
museos rusos en virtud de las sanciones
de la unión europea contra moscú en
marzo el bloque suspendió la
transferencia a rusia de objetos de lujo
una manera de dar un golpe a la élite
rusa pero hasta ahora las incautaciones
más espectaculares habían sido mansiones
y yates estas obras estaban en camino a
su país de origen tras ser prestadas a
museos de italia y jápón
como lo mostramos desde el principio de
la inversión rusa ucrania del mundo de
la cultura siempre reacciona a este tipo
de sucesos construcciones pero también
con actos de solidaridad es el caso del
evento estén without rain' ballet fortis
juntos por ucrania ballet por la paz en
la ciudad de nápoles en italia en esta
actuación benéfica que agotó las
entradas del lunes por la noche para
recaudar fondos para la cruz roja
artistas de los dos países en guerra
bailaron juntos para llamar a la paz
incluyendo a olga smirnova la primera
bailarina rusa que tomó posición contra
el gobierno de putin a ella dimitió del
bolshói el mes pasado y ahora baila con
el ballet nacional de holanda la
escuchamos en que se portan en distrito
sesión es creo que es importante en esta
situación en este momento estar juntos
en el escenario hacer pequeñas cosas las
más pequeñas incluso lo que podemos
hacer por ucrania ese es el objetivo
principal para todos nosotros por eso
estamos aquí por eso estamos tratando
esta noche
flight vamos a hablar ahora de otro
conflicto que finalizó hace 40 años pero
cuyas heridas siguen vivas la guerra de
las malvinas una exposición en el museo
imperial de la guerra de londres ofrece
un recorrido memorial de estos 74 días
de conflicto armado entre reino unido y
argentina en el archipiélago situado a
más de 12.000 kilómetros de la costa
británica una guerra corta pero cuyos
efectos se siguen asintiendo hoy en día
en los dos países
ah
[Música]
y de una conmemoración a una celebración
la de ricardo chanito donde el primer
chef venezolano en recibir una estrella
michelín por su restaurante mono en hong
kong con la cocina latinoamericana pero
con un toque francés porque ricardo
cháneton nacido en venezuela de una
abuela colombiana y un abuelo argentino
pasó por el mira sur de montón en el sur
de francia y ahora quiere ofrecer una
ventana en asia a lo que él llama la
refinada gastronomía de américa latina
estamos dándolo todo y tratando de poner
el nombre de venezuela y todo lo que
representa venezuela muy en alto no
creo que eso es súper súper importante
de remarcar y también bueno teniendo una
estrella en venezuela significa que
latinoamérica también tiene tres demás
estrellas si tú ves el resto de
franceses con esta miseria y por todo el
mundo pero latino me canso un poco y los
hay pero está creciendo poco a poco y
hablando de estrellas en el continente
africano muchas voces de artistas
musicales poderosas irradian a una
escala internacional con sus nuevos
proyectos con sus mensajes de esperanza
y empoderamiento docsalud se convirtió
en una de las principales raperas
feministas queer de sudáfrica su
formación en producción musical y su
breve paso como drag king allanaron el
camino para sus habilidades de creación
de ritmos y su amor por el escenario con
motivo de la salida de su nuevo ep haier
shows ellos superior nuestra colega
mayor y age de nuestra cadena hermana en
inglés se sentó con ella en parís para
hablar de su carrera y le preguntó si
sentía una presión al ser considerada
una abanderada de la causa lgtb y en
sudáfrica
pero no siento ninguna presión porque es
mi identidad natural es parte de lo que
soy
berlín así que estoy orgullosa de ello
pero también trato de normalizarlo al
mismo tiempo siempre hay dos caras de la
moneda representas a una comunidad pero
al mismo tiempo intentar normalizarlas
[Música]
willis nos despedimos con otra artista
africana se llama pongo es de angola y
mezcla pop rap y futuro su nuevo álbum
shakira se estrenó el primero de abril y
como lo muestra su canción en linda es
un disco hecho para hacerles bailar
gracias por su confianza y cuídense
lamento que intentaron afrontamiento no
hay como años de tratamiento pasar a tu
estropee la mente
[Música]
davis que sativa
existe que está
quizá primera vista
el ine
[Música]
y tal vez